[Music]
this lecture is about famous games by
top drum masters and now we have another
famous game kappa blanka playing with
the Whiteley's against food phone aroof
phone are off this is a famous game you
know probably Capablanca was much much
stronger than his opponent i just want
you to see the ideas and how how quickly
not things can go wrong if you don't
play precisely here so Capablanca is
white so if or by the way kappa blanka
world champion number 3 from cuba and he
was a world champion from 1921 to 1927
and you know he held the record of
unbeaten games and I was like believe it
was like more than 5 years he didn't
lose the game or something so he for a 5
we have Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop e5
and we have real Lopez well you know if
he plays a6 we were alibis but he faced
Knight f6 so I guess in 1919 18 they
already knew about the Berlin defense so
castle plate and d6 of course this is
the main theory right now nowadays how
exactly hundred years ago this game was
played actually in 1918 so 90 X e4 as
the main move in this position if you
were watching the recent grant branches
to tournaments in Paris and Lublin they
had many games rookie 196 many games
were played like that
so black plays d6 this is not a best
move it's a concession and who can tell
me the reason why this is maybe not the
best move in this position like the
reasoning what's wrong with this
position
what do you think what's wrong with this
when black plays d6 what is the drawback
so let's see yes Alex absolutely dark
square bishop gets blocked we would love
to get this Bishop on c5 if possible so
- cognition gets blocked and now white
has an opportunity to play active ok to
get the control of the centre absolutely
correct
d4 aggressive approach by capablanca
he's not giving his opponent a break and
he shouldn't you shouldn't play Knight
c3 here give a break no you go for it
right away with the threat of D takes e5
at some point you also have a threat of
d5 now Bishop d7 played by phone are off
I'm pinning the pin and sort of
solidifying the position here now what
to do here how to proceed here it's hard
because you have so many interesting
possibilities here you have a 5 you have
D 5 you have D takes e5 you have Bishop
g5 there's so many things to calculate
you have rook e1 what did kappa blanka
play here
Aashish c4 that's a little bit
unexpected Aashish c4 hmm so you really
going after the space looks like here in
this in this game here it's playable
in d5 no seafood I'm not sure Ashish I
mean you can play the move it's just I
don't think it's the strongest d5 the
problem d5 III go night here and then
what's happening here shake I go here
okay your pond is hanging Ashish don't
don't drop the pawn so you have to
protect that somehow
so maybe thank you so you go here but I
don't know is this is this that that
would oh
maybe even g6 know guys just exhibition
of yourself I don't think dispositions
and if you look at the Nakamura's games
you know he always goes for this
position in wins and that's quite well
and then he just gets a night only 80
plays f5
okay
nice treat
93 is played and now
Bishop to e7 rook e1
just developing white wants to maintain
he doesn't want to commit d5 de he just
wants to develop night goes on c3 but of
course don't even these are normal moves
and now black commits now he takes now
what do we do here from here and I want
you to take control of the game and this
is only a 20 to move a short but a very
nice victory for capablanca Knight takes
d4 Knight takes d4 black probably was
afraid of getting the double pawns he
didn't want to get double pawn so that's
why he decided to go for it to do this
Bishop takes I think he goes Knight
takes and then some Bishop f6 maybe
Bishop takes certainly okay too but
Capablanca wanted him to take on b5 so
that's why he took with this and if he
plays something like c6 you can drop
back on c4 and you keep the bishop okay
you drop back and you keep the bishop so
he played Knight takes d5 he took
actually Knight takes d5 Wow you know
black probably was thinking okay this
Knight is misplaced
here in Castle I think this may be in
accuracy I think he should have played a
six
I think he should have played a six and
that allows the night goes back on c3
I think this age six was important okay
to shift the night back to a c3 because
he plays here and I kind of like what
Capablanca did here
don't rush tink little bit what did
cuppa blah
mmm five you could add he but you're not
gonna get that much out of it you're not
that well-developed to open up the
position normally you won't open up the
position when a couple of things King is
in the middle of the board for the
opponent so you can take advantage or do
you have a lead in development so when
you don't have a lead in development
here and his king is already cancelled
so that's why you don't want to just
play e5 and open it up try to think if
you had a choice right if you had this
idea to put this Knight anywhere on the
board here anywhere where would you like
to put this Knight f5 right now would be
ideal attacking here attacking here all
kinds of threats and that is what
capablanca is gonna do next he's gonna
figure out a way to get that Knight to
f5 how how is he gonna do that yeah
Klim to d3 you could do that here but he
wants to do it with tempo Queen to c2
the excellent good work
yes Queen to c3 now putting pressure on
c7 if he plays c5 then it's a backward
pony Bishop f4 you know if you play c5
it could be some some problems you know
Bishop comes in here okay d1 very
quickly some consequences with you with
these six
so he goes c6
94 threatening to play Knight f5 okay
94 threatening to play Knight f5 putting
pressure
he goes 97 he goes 97 here now yes
bollocks
absolutely when you choose a plan you
stay with the plan right now very
quickly in three moves this Knight is
appearing on a five already very active
putting pressure on g7 putting pressure
only seven as well Bishop f6 attacking
the Queen Bishop f6 attacking the Queen
Queen g3 putting pressure on d6 and
putting pressure on g7 as well okay
putting some nice pressure here Knight
goes to e5 now you need to continue play
energetically here like capablanca six
is interesting but I don't know if you
have much after Knight g6 when he
blockades it okay Bishop g6 he goes
Knight here F for poorer for I go now g6
now I assure you trying to be very
direct here you know but not always this
direct approach is gonna work you know
wait well let's finish this line here
guys first and then we can discuss the
next line don't think this is gonna be
that good for you take take
aha did you see that one
we are okay but I mean
where is your advantage here I don't
think I see I don't think I see anything
substantial here to be honest
exciting okay you take I take no okay
okay
you have a weakness that you need to
deal with Knight takes e5 now threatened
yeah you seven takes and who's gonna
show me the tactic discovery check
Ashish see you got cut all right that
doesn't quite work so let's see what our
she's gonna do
I don't always just think I mean I guess
you should look for that direct approach
you know but not always
just a very straightforward approach is
gonna work okay and be careful playing
f4 because you don't want to weaken the
position
hey you don't necessarily want to weaken
the position ah dh4 what are you going
with h4
okay well first of all what do you go
after this I just kick that strong night
from there I'm sorry yeah but it's five
okay it's like it's one of these
situations where you know you're
attacking without development you know
and we know what could happen here right
Ashish you know now you're already in
big trouble
because you move the night who can tell
me the winning move there you go so yeah
she's very quickly trouble comes in I
don't know I don't know I think guys
this HOH wife it's this is not the right
moment here this is not the right moment
to to risk risk everything you know to
go you know for this attack or broke you
know okay so what's the move you're
suggesting right now correct Bishop f4
is a natural move developing and
attacking yeah developing and putting
pressure on e5 and now what is the next
move that white wants to play here why
do really wants to play this move next
that way he can say completing the
development Alex absolutely absolutely
rook 81 to put pressure on d6 and you
got some nice pressure here very logical
play Queen c7 he comes in though he says
you know you put a rock on the one I'm
gonna put my rook on d6 d8 I'm gonna
protect my position now what do you do
rook a d1 right howdy Luke 88 he defends
it
brooo kd1 rook 88 Ashish think for a few
minutes and raise your hand okay
when you think you have it you have to
calculate yeah it's not so simple
wait a minute how did you do the
checkmate Knight g4 right I take I won't
take you let you take my bishop I know
you want to do that all right let's go
back let's go back guys
let's try to be more tactical here rook
takes d6 excellent yes now he takes back
he has to take bishop takes e5 and now
if you take bishop takes d5 you have
Queen takes e5 hitting the Queen on d6
and threatening checkmate on g7 that
just wins the game right there on the
spot
do you see that tactic so his opponent
realized the trouble here and say okay
I'm gonna go rook t1 now what is the
idea here huh
yes
correct very nice so actually this
position is published in many books how
many of you seen this position before in
a book like combinations of the world
champions many many books many tactical
books have this position
that's just it was very interesting for
me that I came across this game and I
wanted to see the entire game actually
how it lead up to this position so ID is
correct we're gonna go a little bit
slower so everybody can see it
so the idea is we play which move first
Knight h6 check so this idea works
because of a very important theme here
and that team is Ashish background but
before background what's the why this
tactic works here right here why this
tactic works background and overworked
piece overworked piece who can identify
the overworked piece here for black yes
Queen Queen what else the rook as well
right because he's defending the back
rank and is defending f7 so that becomes
the rook over work so that's how the
tactic works you take with the Queen he
takes back and now you play 9 f7 Queen
was getting overworked to there on c7
defending f7 and if I but most important
overworked piece is the rock on f8 ok
because now he's guarding f7 he's
guarding the background and if you take
here now you got check checkmate ok or
Queen e8 so he cannot do anything so he
has to go here to g8 and if he goes to
g8 now what are you going to do
take right you take back on e5 and you
are basically up a knight and 2 pounds
so you're completely winning here ok so
that's the very famous idea okay so you
need to remember so let's go back here
so this is how it works let's go who
wants to try it go
Adi start he has to go here for stand
now why can't we start with Knight f7
Alex take with a queen I take you Alex
Oh Oh very big trouble excellent yes see
when you're trying to do combinations
that's my move order is very very
important okay move order is very very
important okay so remember that so you
go check you go Sears take check
and that wins the game and that's how
kappa blanka won this game against phone
are off very famous game played exactly
100 years ago in 1918 now let's see now
if you can remember this game okay the
entire game that kappa blanka did let's
start go ahead first move e5 over review
of the game 96 what is this opening idea
it's very popular nowadays
what's the idea on the name he's trying
to play the berlin defense right the
berlin defense okay car so now what do
you do
d6 d4 yeah
d6 is a bit passive move so it's a
little concession here because it's
blocking the bishop on a face so that's
why you play d4 immediately Bishop d7
night c3 no Bishop e7 continued
now what do you do rookie one he takes
takes
threaten to play Knight f5 yeah this is
an interesting moment here he probably
should have played a move a 6-year to
push the knight back on c3 he didn't do
that that now this night landed on f5
night at 5 and Queen C that's the way
you put the Queen on c3 so you can
perfectly shift it back on g3 where it
will be very active and attacking Knight
goes here Bishop f4 logical get
everybody involved never leave a piece
in a corner bring every piece into the
game okay you want to bring all of your
pieces into the game now he goes here
and now time time to do tactics perfect
rook takes d6 perfect now you want to
take it if he takes you just take right
a double threat d6 is hanging g7 is
hanging so he goes here yeah so maybe he
should have taken with the Queen here
now but ah but then night h6 guys oh
this is very interesting this check
first not take because if you take take
check he actually takes so you start out
with the check check e here first take
take take mate
okay so or win the bishop so that's why
he started with the bishop
Knight h6 beautiful
perfect and if it goes to g8 you just
take the piece excellent
all right very good over review and
again that was the kappa blanka one of
the couple bankers great winds here and
thank you everybody for coming to this
class and hope to see you next time okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]